pregnancy is the time period during
which a baby develops inside your uterus
it usually lasts about 40 weeks starting
from the first day of your last
menstrual period
these 40 weeks are grouped into three
segments called trimesters
the third trimester begins about week 28
and lasts until delivery most babies are
born at around 40 weeks but some may be
born before or after that time
at the beginning of the third trimester
your baby also known as a fetus is over
a foot long from head to rump
by week 32 your baby is gaining weight
quickly
your baby's eyes can now sense light and
the eyelids open and close the bones are
still soft but fully formed your baby
May kick and Jab forcefully
at 36 weeks the Bones have started to
harden but the bones of the skull and
the connections between them stay soft
allowing easier Passage through the
birth canal
around this time your baby will usually
turn to a head down position to prepare
for birth
by the end of the third trimester all of
the organs including the lungs are ready
to function on their own
your baby drops lower into your pelvis
and could be born any day now
you may feel more uncomfortable during
the third trimester as your growing baby
puts pressure on your organs
some of the changes you may notice
include shortness of breath
heartburn swelling of your ankles
fingers and face tender breasts that may
leak a watery pre-milk called colostrum
your belly button sticks out trouble
sleeping
hemorrhoids
irregular false labor pains called
Braxton Hicks contractions and regular
true labor contractions
if you have any questions about how your
baby is developing or concerns about how
you're feeling talk to your health care
provider